quelques témoins attentifs ce matin
sagement arrêté sur les trottoirs un peu
plus de curieux surtout des femmes cet
après midi le procès du meurtrier du
petit philippe avait cependant une
apparence impressionnantes comme une
manifestation où l'on regarde les
arrivants en donnant à chacun un nom une
identité
les parents les avocats et puis les
journalistes multiplier dix fois on se
reconnaît on se salue on se concerte
parfois jusqu'à l'indécence
il n'y a que des parisiens jette une
troyenne qui renonce à forcer les
barrages policiers pour entrer au
tribunal le procès ne sera donc pas
publics il faut montrer des cartes et
des priorités dans la salle d'audience
l'accusé entre vers 9h45 les débats
commencent dehors la foule redouté à
temps
une quinzaine de jeunes militants
viendront le midi expliqué que la peine
de mort ne sert à rien que la société
est responsable
ils seront repoussées arrêté par la
police sur le trottoir en face du palais
de justice quelques personnes commencent
en criant des discussions mais les 1
face aux autres ne se convaincront pas
et des dizaines de troyens attendent
encore dans l'après-midi sensible au
déploiement de presser de police car ils
sont venus pour entrevoir celui que
certains appellent le monstre